I've been really looking forward to this
conversation I sort of think of you my
conversation with you as launching me
into all of this in some way so it's
your fault so and you know if you've
probably noticed in a lot of my videos I
make reference to you and make
references to criticism and comments
that you make and and we respond to them
along the way so I feel kind of like
you've been at least virtually
accompanying me along the way and that
and that's that's been very good for me
and the project it's been really intense
really busy
luckily I've on sabbatical until January
so I've been able to I'm gonna have to
you know cut back on sort of virtual
presence come January at least a bit ah
but I did get some very good news my
tenure has come through so that's great
congratulations
yeah thank you so I'm gonna officially
get my tenure so there's there's been a
lot like that how about you and you know
you are you through the grueling thing
of returning to your home and so it
sounded horrible every time yeah you
know it's he often you were putting sort
of a brave face on like oh this is
horrible no we're not we're not back
we're gonna be we're probably gonna be
back in our house in the summer like
spring summer just because there are too
many things to to do on the house and we
just ran out of time in terms of winter
and finding a contractor that also that
has been crazy because there's 2,000
houses that need to be repaired and so
just even finding a contractor you know
but it's okay we're we're I'm fine I I
feel like I'm back into somewhat of a
groove I'm getting carvings out and I'm
I'm uh you know my videos are going out
so you know I feel oh yeah yeah you're
doing really good work too by the way
it's really good work Thanks Thanks like
I said I often cite you in the series
and podcasts and interviews yeah I've
I've been thinking a lot about I feel
like a lot of the the language that
you're bringing or the the connection
that you're bringing in terms of you
know the in terms of content
this and then trying to connect that to
religious language and using specific
words I feel has been really useful for
me I find myself using words that you're
using or expressions that you're using
because it seems like they're the right
they have the right they talk about
things in a way that people can
understand because a lot of the problems
with religious language is that a lot of
the words have been ruined they just be
completely ruined it's okay well don't
understand what they're what they're
referring to and it feels like a lot of
the words you're using are helping to to
find another way to talk about things so
that people know what's going on with
like what are you talking about thank
you for saying that because that was a
you know that was an explicit goal for
me i phrase it from the very beginning
about you know a conceptual vocabulary
and a theoretical grammar and that's
what I would most want to do obviously
I'm gonna argue for positions because
that's the nature of what I'm doing but
that's that genuinely is secondary to me
providing you know some deep tools by
which people can reflect and think and
potentially engage in our transformative
processes and it's it's been it's being
very gratifying that I've received the
same feedback from different religious
communities to who I've received similar
feedback from Buddhists I gave a talk
it's on my channel I was talking with
Hamza Soros he was a Islamic
intellectual philosopher and I had a
similar response from from the Muslim
community so I think I mean I genuinely
think that's great and so I'm hopeful
that the series that I'm working on now
because I'm putting a lot of work into
it both theoretically and sort of
research and Pyrrhic all you know sort
of participatory observation I'm hoping
that that that will also be the case for
the next series so thank you for saying
that
that's very important to me yeah yeah
the concept of relevance realization I
feel you know when just saying it is it
can help people understand what is this
about you know yes and and so so I've
been using that term a lot and this idea
of optimal grip and just the idea of
finding the balance between two
opposites that the way that you are able
to create analogies in different spheres
about you know the the problem of the
problem for example of thinking that
efficiency is gonna is if you just get
more efficient that it's gonna work it's
like no it's not gonna work because then
you're lacking you're gonna miss the
other aspect which is to give yourself
flexibility in order to yeah to
technically and and so I think that that
type of discussion is so useful and can
help people understand why a lot of
utopia's are just not possible they're
actually not possible because you always
have to leave your leaving buffers and
leaving you know when people talk about
let's a kind of eugenics or some type of
eugenics you can see that that it even
rationally can't it just reasonably
cannot work because you don't understand
some of these marginal characteristics
that you think are useless right now you
just don't understand why they can be
yeah I think I think nursing around in
our genetics is yeah I agree with that
argument completely as you as you well I
do I just I think it's I I think the
frame problem all the all the unknown
side effects and the fact that because
the way genetics operate they're gonna
be dynamically sort of self-organizing
in ways we can't foresee so yeah I I'm
deeply suspicious of that I mean I'm
deeply suspicious of all utopias I make
that very clear in this series a lot
I mean Alexander bard has criticized me
for that long length you know that you
you can't leave the people without a
vision kind of thing but yeah I'm very
I'm very wary of utopias precisely
because of that kind of concern they
seem to be it's hard to see them as
anything other than hubristic right
there it's hard to see them as anything
other than that for the reasons you just
articulated yeah I think that one of the
things I mean so this is as I kind of
discovered your series at first when we
had our discussion you know it was it
was great it was we were kind of
discovering each other and then watching
your series on the one hand I was like
this is awesome this is awesome and then
other things I was like of course and
part of what I would like to do I mean
I've tried to show that I I take
responsibility in the
meaning of the word of making myself
available respond to people and to
respond to people in good faith and
respect and even with affection
I keep that's is what I want to do and I
keep showing that I this is not just
empty words I think it's fair to me to
say
I keep exemplifying that that is
important to me and I want to give I
want to want to give you an opportunity
to do that if you wish to take this time
to do that I know I trust you I you know
the same way I trust Paul but Paul and I
will disagree but like I say I often try
I trust Paul and I trust you often more
than I trust people that I might share
the same metaphysical presuppositions
with because I get I am convinced that
you know because you know we've spoken
at length at least a couple times I've
seen you a lot I watched you a lot I see
you in interactions with Paul same thing
with Paul right and also now I'm
entering you know conversations with you
know people that are deeply influenced
by you like JP and so and also I'm
entering into conversations with Mary
well what I want I'm try to say there's
I trust people who are like like
yourself and Paul precisely because I I
get I have a conviction that you're
coming to this in good faith and I'm
much more interested in that like the
last the video that you commented on but
and I commented on that too I thought
the video that JP had Mary made in
response to I thought that it was
excellent and I perhaps like to talk
about the one of the points they made at
the end because I've been thinking a lot
about it because I thought it was a very
very good point and they did they didn't
quite craft it into what I would
consider a coherent argument so I'd like
to steal minute a bit try and build it
up into a stronger argument and then
discuss it with you at some point
because I found that I found that really
really interesting the three of us are
gonna all talk soon by the way mm-hmm
but you that's what you specifically put
up I wanted to put my hand up no no it
was with Jordan Hall - you did that was
a journal
later in hall conversation the whole
time I was like yeah it was mariya and
JP that you put the thing up about
infinite relevance realization yeah it
was and I wanted to talk to you about
that too so there was two things yeah
okay so we can start to anything maybe
we can start to talk and talk about God
because I guess that's
[Laughter]
keeps coming back up and and so and so
and so I mean I I've been kind of
following what you were saying in terms
of non-theism
and I understand I mean I understand
Buddhism and Daoism in terms of non
theistic religions my I guess my big
question is where do you put mind in
your system like where at what level of
reality does it enter into because if
you even if you look at these non
theistic religions in practice when
they're actually practice they're always
ends up being a hierarchy of minds that
appears in in the practice of it and so
even though you can say something like I
mean even Hinduism ultimately if you
look at kind of Advaita Vedanta Hinduism
like it all moves towards non-being but
then there's a hierarchy of beings that
appear right away right after let's say
the statement of non-being and then you
have either of you know how your body
satva or a hierarchy of gods or whatever
you so my question is how do you like
where does it come into your system and
the the second question is if like
Christians let's say monotheists want to
put it up as high as possible but they
want to put it up as high as possible
and sure and you have the idea like if
you look at pronouncements about the
divine nature it's always it always
looks like something that is
non-theistic like if you look at the the
pronunciations of the mystics on divine
nature it always looks at and I cite
them I psyched up I give credit right I
give credit to saying like some of these
ideas like the term epic cases and
others I say I attributed it to the
Christian mystics I I don't try and
steal those ideas I make clear I make it
very clear that you know those ideas are
present there but so so I guess my point
is that even even if you let's say in in
in Trinitarian theology you say
something like the divine nature cannot
be spoken of the divine nature is is non
being you have st. Maximus who talks
about the God as being being and
non-being together something like that
you know like this this ultimate aporia
oh yeah
but then as soon as there's let's say as
soon as there's manifestation as soon as
there's manifestation as soon as there's
you know persons let's say anything
specific anything that you can say
anything that you can say even
negatively like that then there's mind
appears right and so that that to me is
so I guess like I'm trying to understand
like how you so if you want to not have
let's say God like where does it appear
in your system and then also if you
don't want to put it somewhere like in
the system like then you have to me you
have the problem of Maya you have the
problem of everything's an illusion this
this the you know the notion that the
manifestation is is always inadequate
like as always is always you know
verging on nothing you could say sure
sure nothing in the pejorative sense not
know nothing in the pejorative sense yet
yeah yeah okay so that's a really
complex question so I might need to talk
for a bit I mean the answer is seven
it's not going to be like that right so
first of all I want to acknowledge that
and I mean and I can strengthen your
argument by pointing to the fact that
once you get sort of beyond platanus
Neoplatonism goes that way too you see
uh you see a hierarchy of godlike beings
for example in proquest so is that a
general tendency I sure so I want to
acknowledge that I'm a little bit
hesitant to say that you know everything
does it Zen Buddhism I think is really
straight on on on Thea's own sort of all
the way up but we can talk about that
maybe another time let's take it that at
least there's a preponderance phenomena
that supports your claim I think that's
that's that's fair I don't want to I
don't want to offend any Zen Buddhists
who might be watching if they know we
just don't do we don't make any images
and have any persons so things like that
um so let's turn it over then I mean
there's two questions that we we we have
to distinguish and and they interact but
they shouldn't be identified
one might be and I tried to talk about
this I tried to make a distinction
between metaphysical necessity and
psychological indispensability and I
hope you accept that I do not treat
psychological indispensability as a
dismissive thing it's not it's not like
a new atheist kind of oh you know and
you're just dismiss it aside right it's
it's much more that I take it that there
are certain ways of framing our reality
there might be indispensable for
people's relevance realization to create
the meaning that they need for their
lives okay so that I mean that's not the
same thing as just saying oh you know
people have these illusions or stuff
like that it's not it's not intended
like that so might it be the case
because the reason why I'm saying this
is Paul has specifically made this
argument in my presence and asked me to
comment on you know that it might be
that in Paul yeah so I mean part of it
is I wanted to be very charitable to
Paul out of good hospitality he invited
me on and so I was trying to be very
well I wanted to be anyways because I
liked a lot but I was trying to be very
responsive but there was it was a I
couldn't quite understood it cleared I
we sort of run out towards the end cuz
the argument had culminated if he was
making one kind of argument or another
because the argument he seemed to be
making is we need to get into the spirit
of finesse in order to enter into a
proper relationship with God it's a
pesky lien argument and that the best
way we can get into the spirit of
finesse is by taking a personal lista
Corian tation and then that's how we
ultimately relate to God and I and I
sort of I did I didn't have any deep
criticisms of that but I'm afraid that I
might have I might have been unfair to
him in that because I just sort of
translated that into my my mind into
this notion of well you know yes that
might be indispensable for people they
might they might that might be the only
way many people can trigger the correct
you know full being finesse to get into
the proper relationship with ultimate
reality or whatever we were what neutral
term we want to use until we talk more
deeply about God and and let me give me
just so your your viewers are clear or
the analogy I use well the example I use
about distinguishing indispensability
from necessity
I'm not bilingual by any means I'm not
like you so English is is
psychologically indispensable to me
I mean I can't do this I can't do the
work I can't write without it I just
can't do most of my complex meaning
making projects right but that doesn't
mean that I should conclude that it's
metaphysically necessary in that all
cognitive agents have to think or speak
English that's that's a ridiculous claim
so it's very if there is no
contradiction between saying something
is psychologically indispensible again
not under dismissive sense it's really
matters to me English really matters to
me
right and it's really it really
contributes to my functionality from
concluding that it's metaphysically
necessary so I sort of translated in
Paul's argument in my mind - oh yes you
want to get into the spirit of finesse
that's the proper orientation and you
take on a personal istic framing and
that gives you access and I thought
that's an argument for a sort of
psychological indispensability
I immediately also thought there are
also ways in which people do this in
personally I mean that wisdom is a
religion of finesse that does you know
interactional psychosomatic stuff that
gets you deeply into a flow state of
finesse state um and it doesn't in in
fact when you're in you're in Tai Chi
you're not in any kind of personal istic
mode so again it strikes me that I could
I'm just trying to be very respectful
there I can deeply understand what a
Christian says you know this is seems
right indispensable to me I I just don't
go the next step and say I think it's
metaphysically necessary so one one
thing we might think is it's clearly not
metaphysically necessary and it would be
my argument because as you said there
are you know they're there they're the
exemplary figures that don't seem to
need personalistic language to describe
the ultimate with all within all of
these traditions you know Platonists in
the Neoplatonic tradition at least some
at least some of the the mystical
writings i've read with the within
within christianity you know Eckhart
famously said you know God save me from
God and things like that
and so I don't know if it is so this is
what it comes down to I don't want to
deny and I don't know if you would like
Mike I'm gonna use this word I won't
want because I think it lines up with
you but maybe not I mean I think
personalism is at least John Hicks would
like it this is a deeply symbolic way
right it's in that it's psychologically
indispensable for people and it might be
indispensable in it beyond the personal
like an individual indispensability
there might be sort of cultural
historical reasons why certain for
certain groups of people
something could become indispensable to
think and relate to God through like the
symbolism of personality I don't know if
for reasons I've tried to articulate if
that license is any claim towards it
being emitted being a metaphysically
necessary and therefore an inherent
feature of ultimate reality per se now I
guess the question then becomes if and
this is part of the the argument I
wanted to make like if we if we go that
way then we're into you know there's
some sort of analogous relationship to
personhood and godhood if you'll allow
me that term I don't mean any disrespect
by it usually I hope you understand that
I mean effort uses it's sort of
presumably it's right and then here's
the problem I have I mean I'm just I I
I'm deeply I made this argument in a
series so you perhaps are familiar with
them I'm just deeply impressed with
Goodman's argument about similarity
there's no logical algorithm for
similarity there's no rule for deciding
similarity because similarly everything
is infinitely similar in dissimilar and
I mean I mean and isn't that technically
the case isn't it is equally legitimate
to say that God is totally not like a
person as much as he's totally like a
person and so Goodman's argument seems
to have purchased here so I regard the
issue I regard the argument about
whether or not even its synthesis you
know symbolically true if that means
something beyond psychological
indispensability
I regard that as as
for the reasons I just tried to
articulate I regarded that is just
undecidable I don't I don't I don't
there's no way of coming to a conclusion
that you know it's ultimately this is
the best kind of a similarity that the
personal similarity I just don't I just
don't see that if best means something
beyond it's often psychologically
indispensable to people so that's that's
that's what I sort of stand now well I
look I haven't answered your second
question I did say there was two but
I'll let you respond to the first thing
I am keeping a mental thing that you
want to want me to place in the ontology
where it is it did you guess where yeah
where it is but I wanted to say first I
wanted to separate that first question
from the ontological question because
they're often they're often spoken
together and I think it's often
confusing to speak them to address them
together so I want to pull them apart I
want to give you a chance now to respond
to that first question right well I
think I mean the way that I that I would
approach what you said is it brings back
the problem of Maya the problem of
illusion because let's say our
experience of person or the experience
of a relational experience of a being
that is like you said at like like me
this is different from me and that
communion that you experience that has
to come from somewhere
right it has to come from somewhere
ontological II it has to come from
somewhere metaphysically but if it if we
can't we can't place it then it is
illusion then then it is then it has to
be a kind of a kind of or a kind of a
kind of Maya kind of yeah and and so to
me that is that is one of the reasons
why like you said for sure I think that
Eastern Christians they don't they they
don't see God when we say everything
everything we say about God is an
analogy it is never speaking directly
about God so when I say God is his
person I don't mean it in the same way
as I am a person but what I mean is you
could say that he is the source of
person
he's the source of these things oh good
yes exactly but he is not he's not a
person in the same way I'm a person
every you know everything we say about
God is always is always how can I say
this is always missing the mark and I
think that that's really important in
terms of theology is that there is no
every word we use about God is not how
can I say this if we say God is love
there's a there's a hierarchy which mean
the way that we say God is love is is
like the source of all manifestations of
love it's never mmm equal to my
experience of love or whatever so it
always kind of moves towards this
infinite and so that to me that that so
I guess I then you know you'll have to
answer the second question because I'm
bringing it back to the second question
which is okay where does it come from
like yeah okay so but there's yeah sorry
I'm gonna be a bit of a philosopher here
I want to go step by step that's okay
because I think III I mean I want to be
fair to both you and to me and so I'm
gonna try and so I like the move you
made and that and and and that's how
I've sort of tried to think about it to
be fair to me I tried to think about
what people are saying is they're saying
like God is the source of personhood but
God of course also the source of ocean
hood he's also this the source of tree
hood he's right I mean that's the sort
of the Neoplatonic idea right and again
and you know sort of they didn't die
Anissa sort of does this he says you
know you could you could even say you
know God's a stone and that the Bible it
II quotes verses when God's compared to
a rock and he says you know and so I I
guess what I'm trying to get at is why
does I there might be an implicit claim
here so I'm asking you I'm not forcing
it on you right that right when I'm
communing with again godhood ultimate
reality whatever the wheel they're
really real as people often describe it
phenomenologically so at least that's a
somewhat neutral term because if he
except on a law that seems to be a
converging thing I don't think the the
ground of my personhood is a purse
like within me I I mean this is gamma
saw like a Jungian idea I'm not I'm not
saying that it's I'm trying to point to
other people who have talked in a
similar manner or Tillich talks about
you know the group the grounder of my
being right the existential and I don't
think that's a person and to be fair to
me I tried to articulate that I tried to
articulate how the notion the personhood
is grounded in something like you know
the processes of relevance realization
and that there that our relationship to
that is you know something that's a
source and so what I was indicating is I
think a lot of times what people are
doing when they're trying to communicate
if you'll allow me these metaphors and I
know they're problematic when I'm trying
to communicate with external you know
the external ground the best symbol for
me isn't actually the personal level
it's the level of my ground right it's
the level from which my meaning-making
in my consciousness and all of those
things emerge or maybe I don't know
maybe that's something like people used
to mean by a soul I'm not sure but I
think of that as well I don't like what
soul became and just sort of a Descartes
yeah yeah okay so that's why runs I'm
pretty good in quotation yeah and so I
think in fact I think that when you look
at the Mystics that seems because they
make when they're making identity
Clint's cuz they do make identity claims
so often say I am a one with God and
things like that I don't think they mean
that they're communing with God at the
personal level because they don't talk
that way they talk about dropping into
the ground of their being and that that
is the only thing that allows them to
commune or participate and I don't think
that's in any way an illusion I don't
see why that has to be an illusion I
mean I I tried to articulate all kinds
of language that I think makes that a
viable way to talk so I don't think I'm
committed to the problem of Maya by
saying that I think what I see happening
you know in a lot of the non-theistic
claims is that people are saying no no
the vast the the deepest way right the
deep calling to deep as it says in the
Psalms right the deepest part of me is
actually there is is the grass
of my personhood is not itself a person
is it's something deeper more basic and
I think there's aspects of that I mean
that's where the deep participatory
knowing comes in the way my psyche is
self-organizing and and the way it's
self presencing and all of that sort of
thing I think that gives me much better
if you'll allow me analogs
although again given my own argument I
can't give you a logical argument that
that's the best because I think throw
logically equivalent so I'm back to
saying I find that clock captures a lot
of more of the phenomenology and and
therefore is more responsible to the
psychological indispensability than the
level of personal language yeah well I
maybe because the person maybe it's just
the problem of what a person is because
we're we're hitting a rock here because
you know you you read in the father's
you read in the Mystics they always say
you know you are not your thoughts
you're not your your feelings you're not
yours all of those things that actually
doesn't constitute your person like
you're a person in Christian language is
is an instantiation of a nature like
that's a person and so there's a there's
a nature which is human nature and then
a person is a is a person like it's a
human and that's what that's what a
person is and so it's it's it's the it's
the actual it's the landing of a nature
it's a land it's the landing of the
nature in in in an actuality
like so so it it has a are you to be a
little bit more specific sorry for
interrupting because yeah I don't I
don't want I don't want to lose because
I think I'm gonna be misunderstanding
you I let you go on so it so the word
when we say I just worry about I'm just
worried about everything everything
instance II it's a nature right like
trees instantiate tree hood I mean
that's the Platonic exactly well you
would say I mean yeah that in Christian
languages the opposite like it's it's
it's it's the opposite of this I mean I
don't have a problem with this emergent
thing but yeah like like give me the
language with the top down let's say
yeah Jonathan it wasn't a challenge
question I wanted you to I need to I
need to
I need to I need to see where the
specificity of personhood comes in other
than in the instantiation of a nature
because everything instantiates its its
nature exactly well everything exactly
but so okay of that is hike in the
notion of a hypothesis like that's yeah
yeah that's the idea of a of a person in
terms of Christian language you know
like it it's a it's a it's an it's an
actual tree it's not just it's not so
that's what to me but you see so it's
fair to say you see sorry you see
personhood in the the the being I meant
as the active presencing of a tree you
see a personhood in that oh wow person
in the sense of hypostasis like in the
sense of in the sense of I mean not in
the sense of can I say this not in the
not in the common sense that we
understand person in the sense of an
individual or like a human individual
but but but there's more to that I mean
that human individual sense we extend
moral rights and privileges to it I
extend those to you that I wouldn't
extend to a tree because I consider you
a person I mean obviously it does it
does also depend on on the nature of
what what is being instantiated and so
but so so the idea like let's say in
terms of understanding personhood in
terms of Christianity the way that we
understand personhood is is is that in
commune it's it's almost like emergence
you know these sound like emerges that
as a person I am in communion with other
persons and that is that is what makes
me exist as a person because I am in as
a person as an instantiation of my
nature in communion with other
instantiations of the human nature I
that's how we exist as humans that's
what makes people that's what makes
that's what makes human and so and so
the instantiation so the Trinity is what
makes God no III don't need not clearly
understand the Trinity but I'm just
trying to help
to help see things a little maybe a
little differently than because I feel
like we always confuse a person with
like an individual in the sense of my
individual rights and my thoughts and my
feelings oh no no this this is good I
want it I want to go with this carefully
so thank you that was first of all very
helpful I mean because I'm very familiar
with the notion of hypostasis because
I'm deeply I Undine it you know it's
it's a it's it seems to emerge in
literature and floatiness
right and and I and to be fair to me
many people describe it this way they
they regard the emanations of the
hypostasis it's something non personal
because of the way you you know some of
the things you're saying we tend to
attribute certain mantle and
dispositional properties to persons that
the the hypostasis don't have for
example so there seems to be a key key
thing in that what you're saying it if
I'm understanding you and please
interrupt me by misunderstanding it
because I interrupted you okay um what
you see it did me saying is there's two
things the first is at least the Eastern
Christian I'm pretty confident that I
didn't I didn't hear this at all when in
Protestants of course when I was growing
up so but I I want to be careful here
but I'm gonna take you as an authority
of Eastern Christianity sorry for
putting that hat on you but you're the
only one here in the dialogues like that
I do what I can do so you're saying
there's a sense in which the idea of any
of that any of that like emanation right
I don't know what you like you said
instantiation as a process as opposed to
just a label any of any of that
instantiation right the high post
ization of your let me to turn it into a
verb you regard that as kind of that's a
personal that's part of the personal
dimension and then there seems to be
something specific in that instantiation
of human nature that makes human persons
if you'll forgive me as opposed to tree
personhood is that am i understanding or
sure in the sense that so the way that
the
it's a Maximus understand it is that
there is a there's a hierarchy of
nature's you know and and the human
human nature because it has mine because
it has meaning because it makes and
participates in meaning it gathers like
it also gathers all the other natures in
himself so so the human person gathers
all the nature's in himself so the image
that st. Maximus talks about is that the
human person is like at the top of the
mountain he's in the center he's in the
centre he's a young and he's in the
middle and he gathers all the nature's
in himself and then when he does that in
love then he unites himself with God
like it's actually by doing that he's
actually uniting himself with God I mean
I understand it so I'm not gonna make an
identity claim here but this reminds me
of Aristotle's notion that everything
has the form but the human mind is
capable of gathering all the forms into
itself and then you get Platonist this
idea that that allows that that gives
the human mind a capacity to conform to
the source of all before yeah yeah that
is definitely that is definitely how
Christians see it but they don't they
don't they really do see it in terms of
of love like and the reason why they see
it in terms of love is that it prevents
the problem of the the hypostasis or the
actual manifestations of things being
secondary or being illusions no no I get
that
so remember I have noted you making that
point and I I take it I take it very
seriously so I do want to come back to
that point because this is really
important in town in terms of
understanding why Christianity is is as
part of the thing why Christianity is
also part of what made science so
powerful you know we believe that the
instantiations are real yes yes yes and
the and the idea that the Christianity
okay you've got you've triggered about
four things in my mind I'm sorry no no
no that's good okay so first of all I
want to go back so the question now
seems that
maybe then if I'm happy to extend sort
of personhood in that sense if you want
to use that term to that notion of the
process of hypo station with the idea
that what is high post at eyes oh my
gosh is is it is not illusory so that's
fine but then the question becomes like
then we did it we ended up doing it and
we and you sort of agreed with my
presentation back to you that I'd
understood you that mine seems to be
something ontological II different in
that it is it is a logo so forms it can
gather and gab forms belong together and
that gives it an ability to conform
source alright and so the question then
becomes I guess for me again is the
degree to which I see the logos as
equivalent to my mind and and that's
that's that's gonna be a little bit
tricky I understand what you're doing
here but maybe let's ask this ask the
question this way that's look at it this
way and so let's say you say that that
mind is different because it's a it
gathers right just able to gather and it
created its sees and participates in
patterns okay so in terms of of your
let's say ontology does that come to the
human person and then stop or does can
you see mind above in higher beings
well why I was hesitating I'm sorry I
didn't mean to be obscure is the term
mind has multiple reference I even have
a talk on that right oh we when we use
the word mind nowadays we we point to
many different things at many different
ontological levels that have different
ontologies have different way of mean we
people do this to be very sure that they
mean brain sometimes yes they they mean
information processing they mean
behavior right they mean like what
language communication they mean
participation and culture they mean you
know what's available to us in
distributed cognition through call they
meet all of those things and the
disciplines that study them don't speak
the same language don't use the same
methodology don't gain to gather the
same evidence so that's why I'm hesitant
about just using
this word mine because I find that term
deeply deeply equivocal for us that's
why I was trying to shift off of mine
and I was trying to get at you know the
grounding of of our ability to sort of
make sense I'm fine with that I'm fine
with making meaning making sense
gathering patterns recognizing patterns
you know even the idea of relevance
realization let's say use that word so
again if we want to use that expression
that's fine but my question is does it
does it go up to us and then that stop
or does it continue to is there more is
there that as is relevant realization at
higher levels sure sure okay no that's
okay so now I feel like I've got the
question and thank you for giving me
that that was generous on your part but
I do think I do think there is a deep
consonants between the ancient notion of
logos and what I'm talking about in
relevance realization for sure yeah okay
great thank you for acknowledging that
and so I think that it's I mean I and
I'm demonstrating that I'm committed to
this I'm committed to the idea that
there is forms of relevance realization
that exceed individuals and I've
acknowledged this 2jp and I'm doing a
lot of work right now and this is a big
thing you can see it being a big topic
you know in places like rebel wisdom the
idea of distributed cognition possessing
a collective intelligence and there's
been some rather horrific experiments by
the way it's sort of demonstrating this
there's a scientist who literally wired
rats brains together like yeah yeah it's
very Orwellian it and what you can show
is that system of rats yeah right can
solve problems that the individual rats
can solve and so we always knew this
sort of intuitively but now you have
sort of corn to quantify measurement
evidence for this claim so it's no it's
no longer just the woowoo claim right
it's it note so I mean yeah if what's
really frightening Jonathan just to
portend what might be happening because
they've done some preliminary
experiments with humans with direct
linkage through the neural the neural
chips and so yeah that's that stuff yeah
that's scary stuff so let's put let's
put there Orwellian stuff aside so I
think I mean I think I should be and I
have been responsible scientists in
acknowledging I think and the reality of
collective intelligence and distributed
cognition that's why I'm very interested
in the Socratic project because I think
the Socratic project is a project of
trying to do something analogous where
we do an individual cognate where we
take intelligence into rationality into
wisdom and the Socratic project is can I
take collective intelligence bring it up
into collective rationality and bring it
up into collective wisdom and and I
think all of that is viable that's what
I'd like one of the things I'm exploring
in the next series so I think all of
that is the case and you should know but
this is taken very seriously in
cognitive science this idea of
distributed cognition having something
like collective intelligence and having
the kind of problem solving so I think I
think I can I'm happy with saying that
relevance realization extends beyond us
into something I don't know is this
sacrilegious I don't mean it to be but
like the ecclesia a gathering where
people are gathering together yeah and
trying to and trying to form a
cooperative and you see that I mean in
Scripture you have the idea of the
angels of cities you have these these
notions that there are you know that
there are patrons and and those beings
are manifest the the communion of a
group they are like they're the head but
I mean I think that I guess maybe now is
is where I want to get back because once
you express something which I was like I
was like you you're on that you're on
the track that I wish you were on your
Aegina and you Gina obviously takes a
lot of his stuff from from Dionysus and
Maximus you know he translated Maximus
into Len yeah I'm so actually interested
in him because he he's the last great
sort of synthesis in my mind of East and
West Eastern Western Christianity and so
you you because because I let's say I
used to always III think top-down like I
I'm a plate in this I'm a you know I'm a
Christian lateness I think top-down and
then it's all the it's on the
discovering during Peterson and you and
and being in contact with agnostics and
atheists it's like I was I kind of
forced myself to think bottom
up yeah um and to to to think of
communion and to think of things coming
together and and these complex systems
coming up and once you said you said it
seems like your DNA is saying that those
two like the emergence and the top down
in Malaysia the emanation there they're
actually happening at the same time yeah
and his notion of creation I'm still I'm
still committed to that I'm still
committed to discussing us and I think
that that's that that is so that you see
the same in say Maximus he says that
explicitly he talks about there are some
quotes above him where he talks about
how you know when when you and when the
mystic sees let's say the the
particulars separate from their essences
you know and he can see it he also sees
that they're the same like that actually
you know that the the the coming
together of the particulars is the same
as the naming coming from above you know
yeah and what's interesting that yes
totally and I'm reading some Maximus or
a meeting about Maximus right you know
quite a bit because as you said if you
want to understand you're a gene you've
got and Maximus
I'm not claiming to understand in the
way you do understand it takes a lot to
get through get to the language to well
but that's usually what it is for a
great philosophy and have to it's not
just the words it's their it's their
mindset you have to you have to habitus
to it you have to learn how to and have
it and and that's what's often more I
often find that that's what's most
valuable about a philosopher other than
the particular proposition they assert
so I like everything you said and
because I'm trying to I'm trying to get
beyond an ontology that privileges
emergence and emanation and and and why
this connects up to what we're talking
about is you know area specifically uses
dialectic but he writes the periphery on
the division of nature as a dialogue and
many people comment on that they
sometimes call him the Hegel of the
ninth century which i think is a
disservice to era Gina because his
notion of his notion of dialectic as I
think is much more Christian platonic
that it is hey Gillian but but so
because he sees creation is an
inherently dialectical because it is
this this complete independent
raishin talk to bottom yeah right and
for me you know I I tried to indicate
also that that's our best models of
cognition are inherently you know
bottom-up top-down completely
interpenetrating right and so there's
something deeply analogous between how
the mind works and and and that kind of
ontology and so I find I think I could
make a case for that well yeah I think I
just did we all right we already we've
already countenance that ontology deeply
in our practice of cognitive science an
emergence up in some kind of top-down
thing and then and then the idea that
maybe that's the best way because the
problem with each one of the two
emergence has the problem like community
like many people you've pointed out us
but how do you get to these the this
sort of normative right and there and an
emanation has the problem of why doesn't
it just stay yeah the one what is it
what yeah why does it why does it come
down exactly yeah know that if you'll
allow me so first of all I'm happy with
that's what I mean about an analogy at
the ground of my cognition as opposed to
like an identity with my mind see the
top-down bottom-up aspect isn't a
content of my mind is that an aspect of
my will it's a constitutive structural
functional I dose that makes mindedness
possible yeah it is that here are you
okay with me though I agree I mean in
creating in the Christian mystics you
all they really do separate the notion
of noose from the idea of mind or sense
of thinking and and you know the the the
active you know process is that that
noose is this direct connection it's
like no it's like I mean you could
describe it as the ground of your being
in that sense yeah and and and and then
the connectedness would be I don't know
bottom-up top-down as a thought I know
it by participating is right that's
great yeah that's perfect
there's the participatory connection is
vertical and
horizontal at the same time which is by
the way the same thing in dialectic
dialectic is happening ontological e
within the individual and then
horizontal between individuals so I
think I can sort of I'm sort of making
sense of what era Gina is doing yeah
there so but if you look like if you
look at then if once you let's say you
see that or you understand that those
two things are happening at the same
time then when you look at if you let's
say look at Christ's pronunciations with
that with those lenses with the with
that lens all of a sudden you're gonna
see that he's constantly shifting
between between both he's shifting
between the two you know we're on the on
the one hand you know when he talks
about when he says things like you know
where two or three are gathered in my
name you know I'm also here I am that's
exactly it it's like they're in love
they're the logos is is is is there but
then there's also the whole image of the
that of the head of the you know the
idea of the the head of the body and you
know st. Paul has that analogy the head
in the body and so that is more of a
like you get the sense of a more of a
top-down but then he also talks about
the the the members of the body that are
--court that are fitted well fitted
together in love and that is the
totality of the Messiah like the
totality of Christ is both you know the
the head and then the joining of the
members in love and so you get you get
that it's it's is I think it's an
interesting exercise to do is to look at
some of the to look at those and so then
when you get for example an image of
Christ who talks about the seeds you
know when he he tosses the season he sow
the seeds come from above and they fall
and if they fall on the right ground
then they grow and so you have that
meeting of the heaven which comes down
and meets earth and then the the earth
also that say brings forth like God God
God says there's no creation and then
ultimately then you have the image of
the creation of Adam which is the
gathering of dust and the blowing in of
spirit and that's it like that's the -
at the same time if there's the
gathering of dust and the blowing into
the spirit you
okay you have to bottom up like
gathering and then you have the top down
which is like the the naming or the you
know this is wonderful I mean and first
of all I'm really happy to be involved
in this conversation
no no Jonathan this is not empty
flattery you're symbolic skills are
really really really powerful as I
respect them I'm liking what you're
doing now I would I would say in
response I mean the reason why I don't
associate this with classical theism is
air Aegina was persecuted as a heretic
right and so this model which i think is
articulated very well in Erik Gina it's
not clear why he was persecuted as a
heretic either I'm it's it's really
obscure I mean he just sort of
disappears um historically um and part
of the and part of the people you know
the people I'm reading and I believe
everybody I'm reading a their Gino is
self-identified as a Christian so if
this isn't hostile Christic and there's
and part of what they're pointing out is
like this was all this was sort of
rejected and thrown away and it's too
bad that it was cuz it would have been
very helpful for us right now that's
sort of the tenor of what I'm reading
and so that's why I mean I'm very
hesitant to apply this model to
classical theism because it looked like
at least in the West the church said no
right it sort of officially said no no
we're not going that way that's not
that's not how we should understand
things yeah there's also there's also a
there's also a reality which is that to
a certain extent this is gonna sound
weird for a lot of people that there
isn't there's a Mis not a necessity but
there is an inevitability of a certain
amount of suspicion coming from an
institution and that that suspicion the
way that I see the I see Christianity
and maybe it's so very different from a
lot of people I see that there are
different actors and they're they're
playing out a story and so I think that
when we see let's say the church give us
warnings about okay we could use even
let's use an Eastern I so I don't bash
the Western Church are using Eastern
example it's like sure they go after
origin you know it's like they go after
origin it's like origin is bad this is
this but it's like origin doesn't go
away origin is still there
we have Evagrius Evagrius is is brought
back into the christian literature you
using different names of different
saints and pseudo texts and all of this
and so it's like it's like it it never
goes away but there's something about
the institution which in serving its
role it also is has the danger of of
crystallizing and of let's say of
wanting to fix things which is good
sometimes and sometimes can be dangerous
and so it's like you always have to see
all the stories at once I don't know if
that makes sense
that's fair that's fair I guess part of
also yeah I think that's a reasonable I
don't want to get us off track though I
don't want to get oh no no no no and I
don't want to equate criticizing
Christianity with criticizing God or
anything like that yeah I want to keep
those apart I was just trying to tell
you one reason oh yeah another one I'm
sort of hesitant I see the same kind of
attempt to get I think I make a really
strong case for this and especially you
know coming out of norges una within
Buddhism of trying to get an ontology in
which there's the deep interpenetration
of emergence in emanation this is you
know form is emptiness right and
emptiness is form and Nirvana is samsara
right it's the idea that right the form
the emergent right the structuring and
the emptiness the source are completely
interpenetrating because the identity
claim there is not a logical identity
that's very clear from the text so it's
no it's what they're trying to do with
the is is they're trying to say the
emergence and the emanation are
completely completely interpenetrating
and in its in its the realization of
that in the sense not of an idea but of
existential conformity that actually
brings that actually brings reliefs
right that brings salvation that brings
the the the amelioration of dukkha and
so there again like I said I
I the reason why I keep using them sort
of saying I want to say this as
non-theism is I'm not I'm not quite
convinced that sorry I don't want to
call you a heretic I'm not trying to say
that yeah
what I'm saying is the way we're talking
I think it would make a lot of people
who identify with classical theism
uneasy and but it's also a way of
talking that would make a lot of people
in Buddhism nagarjuna for example very
very happy and so this is why I try to
use the notion of non-theism because I'm
not trying to commit to a particular
frame and I'm hesitant to say that I see
this way of talking very prevalent in a
lot of the people that identify with
classical theism so but this goes back
to I mean this goes back to two points
one is the degree to which I mean
because you have this interesting thing
that I keep referring to where you think
Christianity is itself going through per
centrally some kind of resurrection
process um and I think that's very
interesting and then the other one goes
back to the point that I wanted to do
with Mary and JP and that goes maybe
back to the the main thread of our
conversation so if you want to come back
to the other thing about Christianity
I'd be happy to do that but I think that
they said something very interesting and
and it didn't quite but because I
basically see to be fair to be also when
I was talking with JP I was also sort of
challenging or upend psychist
interpretation of sort of a supercar of
sort of a supra-consciousness because
I'm not I don't have evidence of
consciousness I don't even have evidence
of a consciousness for the ecclesia for
the distributed cognition of evidence
for intelligence I don't have the
evidence for anything like consciousness
and and and and and and I was trying to
get at like there's this problem of I
don't see relevance realization sort of
ontological --red and this gets back to
your point of infinite relevance
realization so let me try
let me try and they don't quite say this
way I'm trying to strengthen their
argument in good faith so I'm not trying
to strawman it there's something like
the idea that because I've acknowledged
sort of the idea idea from Whitehead
that possibility result you know I think
possibility is real it's ontologically
real the possibility has to be
structured right in some way and that
sort of emanation is how that plays out
in how constraints are found within
reality constraints are instantiated
from the way possibility is really
structured something like that and
that's our a very neo platonic notion
and you can see it clear and Whitehead
but they were sort of getting married
sort of brought this idea and then and
JP did something interesting with it
that you is that there's something
analogous to relevance realization in
that infinite possibility self
constrains down to the finite things
this is an act of self constraining
that's very analogous to the self
constraining that's at the heart of
relevance realization and it's very much
kind of analogous to love because in
love you you're doing this sort of
you're doing an inherently self limitate
a self limiting thing that's also a self
trending self-transcending thing because
you know our Gina sees creation as as
God's ultimate act of self transcendence
like that is sort of God is sort of all
of the creation still remains within God
right and so there's this ultimate act
of self transcendence and I thought I
thought that was a really strong
argument because you could say okay
there's something analogous it's not the
same as our finite relevant realization
but this this if you'll allow me a
metaphor transfer from the language of
physics there's a collapse of infinity
into finite things it's a self
constraining and we we always find that
bound up with how we care about things
and and so analogy an elegance for us it
feels like it feels like a kind of like
what love is I'm come from being very
hesitant here right and then of course
we and we can enter into a communion
with it that gets the mutually
accelerating disclosure which of course
is experienced as we we can fall in love
with that so I'm sort of prepared to
acknowledge all of that I'm just yeah
but like I say iiiii don't so this is
that this is this is a good this is a
good line
you know um like the way that I that I
would that I see it is similar to what
you say I don't like the I don't use the
word possibility I just use the word
infinite I just I like the word infinite
because infinite can really just mean
non even categorically infinite that is
there it just boundless in every every
manner so you can imagine that that the
notion of of God has boundless so we
have we believe in one God the Father
right and this this this boundless
completely boundless and then the Sun
like the logos is exactly what you said
it's that it's it's the it's the it's
not limiting but it's like the
expression of the boundless and through
that expression that's how limited
things appear but what's important like
I think and that what's important
Christianity this is the most important
thing in Christianity is that the the
expression of the infinite is equal to
the infinite that's the most important
thing that's the most important thing in
Christianity and that's why the whole
the whole fight in the fourth century
was all about that is to say that the
expression of the infinite has
everything the infinite has which is
which seems contradictory but what it
does is that it makes it makes the world
exist like it makes the world exist in
and be real and not just be an illusion
okay so the first thing is I use the
word possibility because I want to use
something that has the same scope but is
paired properly with actuality because
I'm trying to get out of kind of a
metaphysics in which actuality is
equated with realness so so I think the
distinctions are orthogonal I see what
you're saying but I could see I could
say you could have an infinite actuality
in some sense and it might not include
possibility right infinity is a weird
thing so try dating
yeah so and the reason why I use the
reason why I use possibility is because
as I've tried to argue possibility is a
real although not properly acknowledged
ontological category in science itself
there's one thing because you know laws
and potential energy these are all real
possibilities and science absolutely
needs those also and constraints in
biology for example but also using
possibility because it overlaps with
combinatorial explosion so that's that's
why it's my chosen term I'm not I'm not
I'm not committed to it in an idolatrous
fashion in that I'm just it also lines
up with how like I said how whitehead
tries to articulate how God fits in his
model right I thought although he
ultimately says that God has to be an
actuality in a way that I think gives in
to Aristotle put that aside so there's
that so the net that so what up what I'm
trying to get at is is ah yeah I don't I
don't want to get into well it's not
that I want to avoid it I don't know if
I can do anything of value to you or
viewers talking about the Incarnation
[Laughter]
because because I mean like I said I see
I see other places I mean the talc HN
says there's the Dow and the
manifestations but but they're
ultimately one and that one is darkness
yeah right or you know form and
emptiness or one and it's a non logical
identity and here's another point that I
would want to make that there's
something analogous again it's not part
of my mind it's not part of my
consciousness or my intelligence I'll
use those two words okay but this is a
feature in my personhood I participate
in non-logical identity because I'm in
some sense personally identical to the
child that was one years old born in
Hamilton now that child and I we don't
share a lot of properties and you don't
even share any atoms right right and yet
there's so there's non-logical identity
and I think my participation in
non-logical identity gives me the analog
for participating in the non logical
identity between form and emptiness the
DAO in the manifestation or perhaps if
you'll allow me to do right
God and the Sun that's that's again
that's not something in my consciousness
or in my intelligence it's part of the
well I think that's part of again the
logos of my being and I'm also willing
to grant to Paul that when I disagree
with Paul he calls out a machine code I
think it's clear evident it's not a
machine code if he's using that term the
way I would because we have to prep
but he says narrative is our machine
code I and and I I disagree with that
because the Machine like we have to
teach people narrative we have to
practice that way we do practice it you
have to teach kids narrative that's the
narrative in practice i father says you
have to teach them and teach them and
teach them and teach them and teach them
and teach them and you if they're really
watered-down narrative to something like
the Teletubbies like I did this twice
with my kids right and you go through
this alright this is horrible right and
you have to practice and practice is
right and that's why they take a long
time to get a sense of humor properly
they to be able to tell a joke right
there's all this developmental stuff and
we keep practicing it with each other
all the time so I'm not I'm not
convinced that it's part of our machine
code but I think Paul what I could agree
with Paul saying is narrative is where
we practice non-logical identity so
narrative is where we get a temporally
extended sense of self that allows us to
get that non-logical identity yeah it's
the thing is that narrative does for
time what names or identities do for
space like an that is that you in order
to create in order to create pattern in
time you need narrative and in order to
create it's a pattern in space you need
you need things that are connected
together in a certain manner in an old
recognizable manner so that you see that
them as an identity and so narrative
does that in time and yes and it's a
more usual categories and naming does
that in space
let's geometry geometry yeah so John if
you go like or just you know we're good
and so to me that's what narrative is
the capacity to to identify with time
like to have experience early
temporarily extend itself but I think
what I want to say is
if you'll allow me these metaphor I mean
there is there's not only non logical
horizontal identity through time there's
non-logical ontological identity through
the levels of being and I think that
there that people pass I mean because
that's what I'm reading and that's what
I've experienced you can pass into a
trans narrative state-paid perhaps it's
a state that transcends both the spirit
of geometry and the spirit of narrative
in which you get this non logic you you
hate this ability of not to to
participate in non-logical identity that
is not just the non illogical identity
of narrative yeah I think this is this
is probably where this is where I get
the the biggest confusion in terms of so
there's there's a there's a there's a
there's a story that my brother told me
he would he studied kung fu for a very
long time and then story really stuck
with me for a very long time he was
talking to me about the different
legendary swords that exist in the this
kung-fu mythology and he was telling me
that the the very like let's say the
second highest sword in their mythology
was a sword where if you put the sword
in the water all the all the twigs and
the branches and the leaves would come
and would strike up against the sword
and cut and half um and he was and that
was the second most important sword and
the the most highest sword the high
sword was a sword that if you put it in
the water the branches would come and
avoid the sword and would never touch it
and so to me the it's like if you say
something like that you can reach a
state the which transcends narrative I
would say yes and then I would say but
that that when it comes back down its
narrative again mm-hmm like so it's not
so the denial of something in in a
hierarchy the denial of the particulars
actually is the the is the the invisible
essence of their coming together and on
the lower on the lower aspects and so to
me and so if like for example so that's
why you know that's why I I really
struggle with the arguments
sometimes where someone would wit tries
to kind of like step up above religion
and then look at the different religions
and say there are examples of different
of different things and it's like yeah
but if you come down you have to be on a
path and that path is coherent like I
don't know if that makes sense like in
terms of of of the let's say that if you
can reach a state let's say a mystical
state where you're above where you you
you would encounter something which is
above narrative and is above you've an
identity and is like you know this this
kind of infinite moment that doesn't it
doesn't destroy reality it actually it
makes reality real that's exactly how
people respond to experiences of entre
normativity of the really real they come
back and they transform their selves and
they transform their life to try and
bring it closer into conformity there's
there's a there's a inspiration in that
sense it right informs and transforms
their cells there are relationships in
their world yeah well I wasn't denying
that I mean I think I I agree that if we
use those might your language but when
you're coming back down that and that's
where I think you you get the the gap
between sort of metaphysical necessity
and psychological indispensability you
fall into a particular narrative I do
think the different narratives do
emphasize different things I think I
mean I think Christianity speaks about a
and it does the best the best sort of on
agape I've made that argument but you
know I think there are other experiences
that are deeply contributory to meaning
in life and I have good empirical
evidence for this I think flow is really
deeply important and Krissy doesn't say
much about flow that much when Taoism is
the religion of flow it's got a lot to
say about it's got a lot of practices
and you're gonna you know if you want to
if you want to become a much better flow
ER Taoism is the place to go right right
um and I'm speaking not just from the
outside I've been a protect practitioner
for like 28 years so I again I
I trying to and I said to see at the
very beginning on our first talk and so
that not that he gives us any special
authority I just trying to say that
there's a consistency I'm trying to
reject both relativism and perennialism
and I'm trying to use the notion that I
got from cognitive science a synoptic
integration cognitive science doesn't
try to eradicate neuroscience or
computer science or psychology or
linguistics anthropology it's not trying
to put them out of business it's trying
to create an overarching framework so
that they can insightfully talk and
transform each other so that we stop
equivocating in powerful ways about when
we try to talk about mind and meaning
and that's a different thing than both
perennialism and and relativism I'm
trying to I'm trying to I'm trying to
try to get beyond both of those mm-hmm
and that's a different thing
so I'm definitely not I'm not hutch say
oh they're all saying the same thing and
I'm not cats oh they're all talking
about totally different incommensurable
things I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to say either one of those I'm trying to
say no no it's much like what cognitive
science tries to do between the various
disciplines that's what I'm trying to
talk about um and so people often I
guess that's where I'm getting
misunderstood where people are trying to
say John but it's funny I think the the
fact that I get both sides or indicates
that I'm being misunderstood John's
trying to destroy religion oh no John is
actually trying to defend and they're
both sides there I'm gonna suddenly pull
this philosophical rabbit out of a hat
and show AHA right all along I was
drawing you in so that I could Jonathan
I I mean I want I want to take this
opportunity to say and I've said it in
the comments but I want to stay here
because that way it will reach more
people if people can with if they can
use my work and they can return to
Christianity but also they can return to
Buddhism or Islam and Taoism and that
will enrich their ability to find
meaning and cultivate wisdom and
compassion great I'm happy right right
I'm not I am NOT anti religious that is
no no I don't think I don't think I
think it would be very difficult to for
people to guess to come to the
conclusion that your anti religious
I'm not and I'm not simply eclectic and
that's okay okay I mean I think look I I
see we've been going for a while and I
have an appointment in 15 minutes but I
would like alright so I would like so
maybe we could have a conversation
sooner rather than later because I do
want to talk about your project like the
accident project I have like you know
I've been thinking a lot about some
things you're saying and I've and I have
a lot of questions in terms of sure and
I expect you might have criticisms and
I'll take them in good faith all right
try to do I tried to do that here with
you today
well I appreciate iron I love these
discussions I really appreciate it and
let's do that let's try to do it because
I think we last time talk was almost
like a year ago maybe you're yeah quite
a while ago they tried to do it sooner
rather than later I would like that I
would like that I listen because you're
running out of time - yeah the
sabbatical if we could get if we could
maybe get it sometime in December that
would be good all right just send me
some times and we'll work something I'm
very happy to talk to you always
Jonathan you know that I'm looking
forward to when the three of us will be
all together that's gonna be so much fun
that that sounds like a lot so people
who are watching we're going to do
something in Northern Ontario genre
Vicki and Paul Vander clay and Jonathan
Petro all the three of us together doing
a I think it's I think it's like two
days even yeah we're gonna have talks
and meetings and also have a question
period so I think it's gonna be I think
I really looking forward to it too and
I'm hoping people are going to to come
with a lot of interesting thoughts as
well people you even come into the
audience so I think that'll be great
I I agree I think I think what the urban
Abbey is doing it's just just fantastic
I encourage people to get there if they
can because I think it's just gonna be
an amazing thing I'm really looking
forward to it alright John so I will
I'll say goodbye for now and then we'll
have another meeting sometime in
December thanks again great I really
appreciated this discussion Jonathan
thank you very much all right okay well
bye take care I hope you enjoyed this
most recent discussion with John
reveille key as we mentioned in the
video check out my website once in a
while we'll be putting up dates very
soon for an event with John Paul
vander clay and myself which will be in
northern ontario as christmas comes to i
wanted to put up a few things on my
teespring account I have some obviously
Santa Claus exists t-shirts that I
designed with my children and what that
was a lot of fun and also I made a hand
drew a inked version of my logo where
the six days of creation and put in the
inscriptions in English so if you want
to check that out there's a link below
and the YouTube channel you can also
check out my teespring account so thanks
a lot and I will see you soon
[Music]